I'm not spider-man because spider-man is
not at the end credits it was a prank
and I totally fell for it it looks so
real I really was fighting right BPM
Chris but there's nothing there's
nothing there was a total letdown Apple
god I feel like such a dork
mr. Simpson such an end credits teaser
does not exist I fear you must have
imagined it it's real it's real I mean
it's not really they they made up it's a
prank but it existed yeah yeah so we uh
there there there there
can you thank you yeah so we we stayed
for the whole end credits and uh my wife
was just like there's nothing there at
the end and like it asshole I believed
my brother it looks so real now there's
a whole making of like how we fooled
everybody
I just kept I just kept telling her I'm
just like well Doug says there's
something and she's like have you seen
anything I'm like jelly and she's like
Joss Whedon said there was nothing empty
yeah that's what she said matter I'll
just tell her I just I've been running
towards my wife and I'm like I know but
he says he says he saw it on the
internet there's I'm with spider-man and
revenant and wow dude well so and this
is Italy where Iron Man Captain America
Black Widow and all the rest are back in
Avengers age of Ultron of low-budget
independent yeah I'm glad getting some
attention yeah good this wind guy he's
best known for his Shakespearean film
see I heard he was really known for
writing one of the alien sequels I don't
know like that's what people loved him
for uh yeah resurrection like yeah yes
yeah you did a very well uh but um yeah
this is uh this is the Ultron AI that is
kind of created by Tony Stark and aliens
and hey hey you left out the Hulkster at
the Hulkster as well yes it did give
great work rice - and Hogan had a cameo
it wasn't a
he's apparently a scientist I get
reading a lot of scientists so well I
put glasses on my coke boom he's a
scientist
um and the AI goes nuts or does he
because saving the world can also mean
destroying the world yeah we're doing
that um but the Avengers have to go and
find out how to stop this thing because
he's everywhere he's in the internet
he's in pretty much every machine you
can imagine and it's a race against the
clock until he destroys the world pretty
much kind of like the last Avengers
movie uh all right so we can't really
talk about this until we talked about
what we thought the first one uh yeah I
did a veal aughh by years later you know
has anything changed or whatever uh I
thought it was an incredibly
entertaining enjoyable a super fun
well-written dumb comic book movie
communist you think the exact same
goddamn thing yes but I don't admit it
out loud no it's one most entertaining
films I've seen funny quiet they may
give you the gas you know it's one most
entertaining films I've seen like weaves
and moons are everywhere it's great that
paid off this giant experiment that cost
lots and lots of money and it is well
written what everyone's like how
canceled did you say we lost or cause
that's why murder or Oh
um but but but yeah I mean a lot of
people say how can you have you know a
dumb popcorn movie that's well-written
and that that's a good example of it
right there I mean it's totally possible
but the funny thing well-written not
well constructed that's the weird thing
about it it's very it's a very funny
hilarious movie if you really look at
the plot though I'm like oh yeah the
plot stood that's why I say it's a dumb
you know enjoyable comic book movie you
know again kinda like the lego movie
it's like the plot does it make any
sense but they kind of explain why and
how and stuff like that so even that's a
cute little better than the Avengers 10
you know I I mean I think we just got to
take the rose-colored glasses off a bit
um I
cuz the first did
I like the Avengers I like the Avengers
don't get by on keyboards ready get the
dislikes ready it's it's funny because
I'm going to use I'm going to use this
argument to try to prop up the sequel
but in some ways that I hate using that
word cuz it always implies bad but
overrated and like a little just just
just a little overrated I'm not saying
it's a bad movie
yes and I dislike thumbs downs I know
it's a honestly I think it's a fun as
hell movie it was very entertaining but
there's been like this kind of uh like
right from the beginning I think it was
declared the greatest comic book movie
ever made before it even came out which
i think is part of my issue with it and
like maybe could make an argument it's
the greatest comic book movie ever made
but as far as I'm concerned it could
join about a list of maybe seven or
eight other film history and I like just
as much you know going back to Richard
Donner's Superman you got the Burton
Batman you've got uh you know Nolan's
The Dark Knight which to me is kind of
almost the gold standard I I'll just say
it I kind of liked guardians of the
galaxy more than the Avengers and I
really like The Avengers but for pure
entertainment value like the Avengers is
a movie I could see like 50 times and
still be okay I feel like I could watch
guardians of the galaxy till the day I
die like a thousand times and I still
just find it hilarious and entertaining
so so so so there you go and we don't
forget about the what we thought the
first one so we both really liked it I
mean even though we now it's not the
great oh my god this is the greatest
movie ever made but even the sequel my
god
I just can't believe that you know what
there's pacing issues in this movie you
know the series of one-liner you know
the villains I'm a little confused
a little bit just take a wrapper all dry
you know it gets a long movie it's over
to on it well what do you think they
were making a comic book film yeah I
don't know yeah I think we made a little
more cheddar than he really is that
doesn't hold up to the high standard on
the first one the the brilliant you know
what that guy was playing gavagai I mean
it was just like there's no gag on this
no Garrick I think you can see where
we're going and this is why we had to
kind of dis the first movie a little
even though we liked it because most of
the criticisms I'm seeing and I didn't
read any reviews until late last night
after I saw the movie when I start
reading some of the negative reviews
even the positive ones are back handedly
negative I'm like but but these are all
problems with the first bits are you not
sex ain't rawness T in my opinion they
fix some of the problems they do it
because there's more characters ever so
then there's I'm sorry I love the first
adventures but there's like no bold
character in that movie yet it's them
interacting which is fine partially
agent I make Varzi I'll give it I'll
give it this partially to because they
had a number of other movies setting up
this like what do you need to set up
about Iron Man we had three films only
one of which was really that good but
you know the same thing with you know
Captain America we had you know benefit
yeah they run the market so but but
really if you watch The Avengers not
having seen those other films first like
it's they're like cardboard cutouts
almost like it's a series of funny
one-liners and jokes but there's such
there's a lot of characters it's okay
yeah you know I don't know much about
their pet you know what still there
what's leaked I love it they're not
gonna get along well doy you know in
this one you actually find out like
about their past Hawkeye becomes like an
amazingly interesting character I'm like
to a degree though I think it's I think
it's hilarious to think about Hawkeye is
that he may be more boring than Captain
etheric no I was totally on board for me
I don't know I liked it because it was
you know it was very endearing it was
really endearing but the same time I'm
like I thought Captain America was a boy
scout Jesus Christ no I absolutely all
have to be made by boring okay yeah I'm
talking about I enjoy
I enjoy watching him I just mean as a
kid as the way the character is written
like the whole I know if we should say
that for spoiler corner or not because
it is a funny reveal in the film yeah I
mean we won't give a really funny but
yeah we find out he's a he's more of a
Boy Scout in some ways and Captain
America's which I thought was amusing so
yeah so it's one of those things where
it's like they've been a more
interesting to go they dabble a little
bit more into black widows backstory but
still not all the way still not too much
and not in a way that's like Harry
Potter or the Xmas movies where it's
like oh my god we just tell us fucking
something feel like it's like a motel
something like really interesting like
wow I want to know more this is so
intriguing I feel like we're saving up
for a black with a movie that's never
coming I never wanted this black widows
cock tease me early it's what biggest
cat sees going on with her backstory and
I'm like seriously just do something but
but I like is she's compelling so he's
really I mean I think you know my
favorite Avenger Ana's are pretty
compelled like yeah most of the
characters Thor Thor is not compelling I
fucking love flower though I'd say he's
awesome I just like it's a toss-up
between like this Thor thing it's kind
of funny so cut he's the only one that
talks like a big epic major character
and there's just something so cool about
that like when they're done it's like
yeah how do we do it's like at the gates
of Hell or filled with the screams of
our enemies I mean it's like it's just
so awesome yeah this great big superhero
team there's a guide actually talks like
you know part of a big song he talks
like this Tolkien character it is just
so cool yet these people doing the
one-liners and stuff and then thought
saying he's big massive awesome kick-ass
thing it's just cool he's just
Authority's entertaining in the movies
but like if you're asking me for my
favorites he's wait out the thought no
I'd obviously it's either him or Black
Widow I think I remind everyone like
Tony Stark but it's like he makes a
million mistakes and he's just such a
show-off and Black Widow it's like not
just do my own thing fuck you guys well
toy that Tony Stark is the most
entertaining character yeah but I mean
if we're talking characters pretty much
since Iron Man 1 I feel like he's slowly
had the character sucked out of him a
little bit like they've kind of just
like okay we've done everything we can
with Tony now he's just gonna be a
one-liner
you know spewing machine he just
dispenses one-liners like you know Pez
candy like yeah so he's tormented it's
like he's a genius buddy's an idiot get
it it's like yeah I don't feel like any
of the including this one because so
much of it rested on Tony and it's
really just kind of dropped his hint so
I get the end like you know well he's
not gonna do the right thing why cuz
he's Tony Stark and no Ultron is so
confused and torture and weird why well
because he's got Tony's personality kind
of stuck in him he was a product of Tony
Stark so I feel like now we've just I'm
not saying it's a bad thing but kind of
dumb Tony Stark down to this kind of
like archetype of like well he's
tortured that's it what was his really
in the same way they've done I think in
some ways in this movie with Captain
America I feel like well he was frozen
in time and he's a goodie - no you know
what but again I'm a I'll make an
argument for Captain America and this
and maybe this is because of Winter
Soldier as well cuz I love it no but he
this in the first film it's like I
wasn't the Austrians I said I kept
America nobody's favorite character
flood might get America no but you know
in this film like he felt like the
leader like in the first one he was like
he just not some guys hadn't told the
police people what to do it's like well
what are you the leader I guess I you
know it's not just what he felt like
that's a really good point and you know
what's nice he is not a raging douchebag
leader yeah like the house so easily
could you turn him into Cyclops or
Leonardo from teenage Ninja Turtles or
just every lame archetype of just you
just kind of want to punch them in the
face
I've never gotten I want to punch
Captain America in the face cuz half the
times he's right um particularly near
the end of this movie so when all the
others are kind of badasses and saying
they're rogues and they you know go off
you know serve like making their one
liars and stuff you know but he very
much like is is keeping it together I
mean he he doesn't ask for credit all he
does is says he got that reference but I
know they're and so it actually like
these characters actually in many
respects I think are becoming more
interesting and kind of stronger as
these movies progress but not having
said that I will say that the film the
one
two downsides to the film one day it is
hell well no but that kind of goes back
to the first one - is that yeah it is it
is a comic book movie but I mean in like
every meaning of the word it's a comic
book movie but you also got to take into
account that as a film there's gonna be
stuff you're gonna be like wait what huh
and it's a parts of it are very much on
repeat like the first film like hey
remember seeing we're like the whole
goes nuts it has to go against another
inventor when the Avengers don't get
along if it's sort of separate for a bit
all of that comes back but they do it in
a different way and in an interesting
way so I surprisingly didn't mind that
much okay even the climax is very much
kind like you know bunch of robots
flying around they were hitting a bunch
of them and you know they're in a circle
again at some point the camera circles I
mean it's there's a lot of callbacks but
it's not to me wasn't annoying cuz they
did it just different up and they added
just enough let's just talk about the
story because I think that's where some
of the problem comes okay and I'm not
gonna and I'm not saying the issue is an
x-men the recent x-men films had the
same problem is that these stories are
so old now and so dated then when you
try to just turn them into a modern film
without finding a way to kind of twist
it around and update that story it
starts to show I mean they twist around
a little bit they twist around a little
but I mean I know yeah just AQI
we all had the same thought we're
watching this is like what Tony Stark
never saw the Terminator okay no I
ordered my awesome one a Space Odyssey
like I bet this is my problem number two
because this is at the beginning of the
story so this is fine they find Loki's
you know big evil stick and they hear
yes beer sorry and Tony gets a vision of
like the future all his friends are dead
all the Avengers are dead in the kept
American literally looks at with his
dying breath of you could have saved us
and Verizon next scene next scene what
does he do you know I'm gonna use this
thing and create this artificial
intelligence I could totally destroy the
world but probably won't and I should
are you fucking me don't you get it no I
know I mean it's like you bought it
looks like it took me it took me a few
minutes of screen time to figure it out
he thought that was going to be the
future if he didn't do something so he
thought not
everybody is watching this and thinking
like oh he's gonna be like the cause of
it I mean it's like come he must have
seen like Tony Stark he is Robert Downey
jr. let's be honest here alcoholic okay
nice assess what that's what a coke
addict solution would have been no but
it was one of those things where it's
like you know looking at that it's like
you know come on and right after Lansing
you could have saved us it's like well
I'm gonna point to development the one
thing I mean robably make this happen I
mean that's an issue I just the whole
concept of the story
oh the artificial intelligence got
confused like Hal 9000 anything's by
destroying the Avengers that look like
The Fifth Element did it just like all
you ever wanna do is destroy like I
should know there's good things
convincing the humanity as my god it's
making the red dwarf light you know cut
the Star Trek crap it's too early in the
morning um but so that that's kind of my
issue and like listen when the original
Ultron's were written it was like the
late 60s this was hot shit back then
this is 2000 what was coming out yeah
did that like they were this is 2015 now
and I have no idea because the age of
Ultron like I stopped reading comics
because life got in the way
comics have always been that I've loved
them as a friend that's lover
so life got in the way so probably yeah
late 90s is the last time I was reading
anything I read most comics in the 80s
and 90s oh I didn't read the new age of
Ultron that came out was it passed ten
years maybe I know nothing about all
yeah so I don't know if they updated the
story or not but I mean the the story
feels like this version feels very much
like something that would have killed in
the early 80s but now you're just like
wow this is every single sci-fi plot
like I've ever seen like there's no
really new here and that's a problem I
think you did then is our one complaint
you do have to kind of find a way to
update these things like and but to be
fair again in the first film I mean it's
like both films have villains that are
almost laughably not scary but now
Ultron is not scared but they're cool
and they actually start have fun in
mascara you know ultra make all these
speeches and everything at some point
like the whole destroy Saul's minions
and stuff you know and also you know it
gets me to speak you know in hindsight I
and finally he punches them again kind
of like in the first film now my
favorite is when uh Ultron tries to
escape for like the fifth time and then
Hulk earth or somebody busts into his
plane and you just hear over godsakes
yeah I like that stuff Mike my problem
with Ultron I think is the the CGI did
not do it a service because they
animated his face the original Ultron
face is kind of scary looking like a
jack-o'-lantern
I feel like if the mouth didn't move and
it wasn't inner enemy yeah in the
beginning I know creepy was kind of
happy bunch of these wires and like it
right starts moving and everything and
he starts to look like a Smith from lost
in space
fugitive spiders like it's got a weird
CG so it's not particularly scary he's
very funny but yeah like once again I
feel like the villains kind of the
probably the Achilles heel but yeah I
about yeah here's the thing like that
said I I had a really good time I really
enjoyed it you know and the low here's
the thing the slow points in the first
Avengers uh you know are legitimately
like kind of slow and okay can we just
get to the scene why they gotta be
paralyzed for the best forty minutes of
trying to repair this damn engine yeah
you'll forget that the first way bits
are actually kind of boring um yeah and
the right uh but it was fine because it
gives so many other good but there boy
was even in the other phases
come on know this movie's awesome like
and that's what I don't get is like this
film has the exact same problems as the
first one except now that is like oh
well this button sucks
no probably put it but but what I like
is well though is that they take
someone's problem like I said they give
us more character they give us more bad
story and they give us more interaction
there's a scene where they're just at a
party talking and I'm always great you
know I could watch this for the movie I
could hear people buy cigarettes hours
of these people partying which is sad
like because that's all it would take
for you I'm like yeah I could is party
holidays yeah and just watch them
interact you know in the first one
you're seeing him in Iraq for the first
time in this one like they know each
other and they're working off each other
and you find out more about them so when
you get to those kind of slower points
to me there's still much more
interesting than the first one because
we are finding out about well that's
what the first one was missing was
actual character development there was
there was none I honestly can't repay
you right yeah I think further yeah I
got spooked early on because this movie
opens up like an attack and Hydra and
like it just dumps you into it and
honestly the CGI is very bad way it's it
gets better
so yeah watching you're watching over
Jeb either gets better if you're
watching in the first 15 minutes that
Hydra attack and you're like oh my god
this is a bunch of plastic like a little
plastic black widow jumping it is the
most ridiculously CGI like cheap looking
thing but it did they get better after
that 15 minutes and like there was no
real character development it was just
you know one line I'm like oh my god the
whole movies gonna be like this and then
yeah when the characters start
interacting I'm like well this is what I
was kind of missing from the first one
as much as I loved the first one it's a
series of just events that happen I
never feel like I got to know the
characters anymore yeah like this one
who fixes a lot of that problems the
villain I think is kind of even weaker
than Loki and that's kind of saying
something um but yeah so it's kind of
like a mixed bag it's like it fix some
things some things are the same it's
kind of derivative because again I feel
like we're just watching stuff that
happens not a lot of progression like
once again like Fano sends up there
somewhere near the end and he doesn't do
jack like the exact same ending of the
first Avengers like said now he has a
fashion accessory that's it boiler alert
he puts the gauntlet on Oh like come on
yeah yeah it says the same thing says at
the end of everything you know I'm
coming
I'm gonna be in one of these movies wait
10 years um so yeah but it's funny
because I was just listening to the
radio this morning and I'm seeing that
line ever and I was like oh it's getting
such bad reviews oh it's lower license
seventy seventy five percent and most of
the negative reviews are like yeah it's
kind of man I'm like what I think
there's a contingent of people out there
who just want this movie to fail like a
really desperate to capture the magic of
the first one we were there at the first
one now they can't recapture honestly I
think that's why the problem I think
critics when they look back on their
glowing reviews for the first one are
suddenly seeing like you know the little
breaks at the seams and stuff and
they're like oh we got a course correct
like so we got a like you know not like
this movie as much because we probably
over praise the living fuck out of the
first movie and like that's it feels
like some sort of overcorrection like
everybody is thumping on this movie for
things that the first movie did yeah
like they fixed a few yeah I mean the
only two things I will say is yeah the
movies kind of derivative I feel like
plot wise we still really aren't going
anywhere this is just a setup for Civil
War you know and it's the villain is not
as great as it could be the story's
dated but everything else there's more
character development so that kind of
offsets that and it's it's very much the
same thing over again if you like the
first Avengers like I liked the first
Avengers I feel like well I kind of got
the same film again and it was fun I got
the exact film I thought I was going to
see honestly I got the Avengers going
around saying one-liners showing more
character about them you know
demonstrating more about other past and
how interesting you are and how well
they work off each other
stopping a bad guy with robots flying
around and some decent good action you
know nothing quite umpire with like the
whole kidding though you know whatever
that metal whale was or whatever but
it's still some really really good
action very fast and very quick you know
one or two moments where people are
you know but not as much as the first
one we had two applauses and there were
a number of laughs yeah the laughs were
all really good but but for me like I
said in many respect knowing what we
think of the first film I do like this
one a little better because like I said
we do get more character and that is
what I love about the Avengers I love
the character and you still have the
good action and you still go to villain
I'll just say it if these movies were
first if this one came out first we
would be singing the fuck praises out of
this film over the second one it would
be it would literally be the exact same
thing the critics would be going about
if you reverse the film's they'd be
talking about what is the first one
outside knowing it oh it's just not the
same it's this in there like I because I
think you're right this film does a
number of the things better um so I I
don't know I don't get the critical
reaction to this I don't it if you just
want a good time it's the Avengers all I
can say yeah I mean I guess neither of
us were like especially hyped for this
movie me we weren't like oh no I gotta
see Avengers like no this looks like a
fun dumb summer blockbuster that well it
doesn't know but I'm not a huge all Tron
I wasn't a huge Loki person either
because I don't think about our job yeah
like these are like I'm waiting for
civil war in for the Infinity Gauntlet
way I feel like I'm just biding my time
waiting for x-men apocalypse yeah so if
I get against I lack if I can't
entertainment along the way waiting for
those things I all right well I guess it
works yeah I mean it's it's a it really
is like if you like the first film
you'll you'll like this one most likely
um that's really kind of what I'm
thinking unless you like are so
high-tech it's going to be even bigger
even better even more gigantic than the
first film you know if you're looking
for like an even bigger spectacle I
don't know if I'd say it's then the same
yeah that they're about they're about
which maybe is part of the reaction is
they're just like everybody expect to be
ratchet up to some insane level but it's
kind of impossible to do like it's
reversible was the first meeting of
these kids the first time this was done
and they're still continuing this story
and yeah I think like you said there are
so
rose-colored glasses with the
first-known because it was the first
time I was done and nobody knew if it
would work you know we were excited and
we wanted it to work but we didn't know
because we never seen something like
this work so when it does you're just so
happy and so excited uh so you know but
with that said it's it's fun it's it's
enjoyable but it's not like wow this is
a really in-depth psychological study
that's changing my life it's nothing so
really more show than the first one ya
know it's a really not that's one talked
about the first one it's a big dumb
enjoyable summer blockbuster and this
one I think is the same except we
actually get a little bit more character
which i think is even better
so yeah but I would say see it if you
want something kind of like the first
movie yeah yeah but with a little bit
more character and action stunts and
effects and uh I thought was a lot of
fun it was a kick-ass ant-man trailer
before it did yes actually actually
that's the funny thing the only thing
they had two missed opportunities I
think the original Ultron had something
to do with ant-man I thought it was his
personality in there he created him oh
really yeah um and I'm just like I'm
just like well you could have had a tie
in there I don't know why they didn't do
that but I guess they're just like well
what should be Tony Stark in the Hulk
and I guess how would you fit ant-man
it would have been hilarious he goes
inside the a IML computer brain I mean
cool I think the old old Ultron story if
I remember properly the one like from
the early 70s or late 60s whatever like
yeah so uh but yeah you pretty much give
uh I think you can sort of gather from
this this is something you like I mean
if it's like no I want something even
bigger and even grander and stuff like
that it's already great uh one there are
some pretty moments do to be fair um is
it still it's still your big dump I
don't think it ever got Winter Soldier
gritty yeah or like Dark Knight I'll say
I'll say I do think this movie is
benefiting a lot from Winter Soldier
that movie built up a lot of goodwill
that can carry some of these characters
yeah technically Captain America because
knowing what he went through in Winter
Soldier I'm just like all right I'm more
invested in him but yeah this is like
the double-edged sword you have to kind
of see the other movies too but
now for them if I yes see our other
movies huh yeah so um okay yeah that's
my only replaces yeah I like it yeah now
people say oh this is this movie sucks
it's terrible I'm like okay I don't get
what you expected them so yeah so I
pause a lot of fun it was exactly what I
expected a good way uh and I definitely
really enjoyed it so um yeah um I'm
still not spider-man and still pissed
off that I got had it's okay it's okay
they're they're part bear they're game
over each of these movies